TEN TED CRUZ ANNOUNCED HE WILL
SELF QUARANTINE AT HOME AFTER
COMING INTO CONTACT AND
SHAKING HANDS WITH AN INFECTED
PERSON.
WELCOME TO "THE NEXT
REVOLUTION".
I’M STEVE HILTON.
THIS IS HOME OF POSITIVE
POPULISM.
PRO-WORK, PRO-FAMILY,
PRO-COMMUNITY, AND  ESPECIALLY
PRO-AMERICA.
IMPORTANT SHOW, CORONAVIRUS,
THE ECONOMY AND THE OUTRAGEOUS
CHUCK SCHUMER BUSINESS.
WE HAVE AN OUTRAGEOUS LOONY
LEFT AND A NEW JOE BIDEN
COMEDY SEGMENT.
WITH ME LIVE IN LOS ANGELES,
ADAM CAROLLA AND TAMMY BRUCE.
JENNA ELLIS WILL BE JOINING US
AS WELL.
THERE THEY ARE AND HERE WE
GO.
WE WILL GET TO CORONAVIRUS IN
JUST A SECOND BUT LET’S START
POSITIVE.
WE SAW AN INCREDIBLE JOBS
REPORT ON FRIDAY.
273,000 NEW JOBS IN FEBRUARY.
ALMOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
THAN EXPECTED.
ANOTHER 85000 ON TOP ABOUT
WITH REVISIONS TO THE PREVIOUS
TWO MONTH TOTAL.
IT’S NOT JUST A NUMBER, IT’S
OVER A THIRD OF A MILLION
AMERICANS WORKING WHO WEREN’T
BEFORE.
JUST IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT A 50 YEAR
LOW.
EARNINGS CONTINUE TO GROW.
NOW, IF WE WANT THIS SUCCESS
TO CONTINUE, WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY IT’S
HAPPENING.
THE POLICY FOUNDATION.
THE TRUMP HATERS SAY IT’S ALL
THANKS TO OBAMA.
>> BARACK OBAMA LITERALLY SAVE
THE ECONOMY AND THE BENEFITS
WE ARE SEEING NOW FROM TRUMP,
THERE IS A RIPPLE EFFECT.
>> THERE IS A NARRATIVE HERE
EVEN WHEN THEY SAY THE OVERALL
NUMBERS ARE GOOD THEY’RE NOT
THAT MUCH BETTER THAN OBAMA.
>> FRANKLY THESE ARE OBAMA ERA
POLICIES THAT ALLOWED TRUMP TO
HAVE TWO YEARS.
IT WAS A GIFT.
IT REALLY WAS.
STEVE: THAT IS ANGEL THE
WRONG.
PEOPLE WILL THINK WE CAN
SAFELY GO BACK TO OBAMA
POLICIES WITHOUT HURTING
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
THAT STORY IS ALIVE AND WE
WILL SHOW YOU THE HARD
EVIDENCE.
IT’S TRUE THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
AVERAGE ECONOMIC GROWTH YOU
SEE ROUGHLY THE SAME
PERFORMANCE WITH OBAMA AND
TRUMP BUT AVERAGES IS MUCH
HARDER TO CREATE GROWTH AND
JOBS AT THE END IN THE
BEGINNING.
HERE’S A PATTERN YOU TYPICALLY
SEE.
GROWTH IS NEGATIVE DURING THE
RECESSION AND IT QUICKLY
ACCELERATES AS THE ECONOMY
BOUNCES BACK UNTIL FALLING
MORE GRADUALLY UNTIL THE
RECESSION HIT.
IF THE OBAMA ECONOMY HAD
LASTED THE SAME LENGTH AS THE
PREVIOUS ONE, WE WOULD’VE GONE
INTO RECESSION LAST JUNE BUT
WE DIDN’T.
WHY DID THE TRUMP ECONOMY.
[INAUDIBLE]
THE REST OF THE WORLD HAS BEEN
GOING DOWN.
THE EXPLANATION AND THE POLICY
LESSON IS THE CHANGE THAT
HAPPENED RIGHT THERE.
THE 2016 ELECTION.
A PRO- ENTERPRISE,
PRO-BUSINESS APPROACH.
DEREGULATION ON ENERGY
UNLEASHED INNOVATION AND MADE
US A NET EXPORTER OF OIL FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
TAX CUTS FOR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS.
ALSO HIGHER PRODUCTIVITY WHICH
ENABLES HIGHER WAGES.
THE TRUMP HATERS SAY THESE
POLICIES JUST HELP THE RICH.
THE TRUMP BLUE IS A
BLUE-COLLAR BLUE.
I HATE TO SAY THEY ARE JUST
CONTINUING THE WAGE GROWTH
STARTED UNDER OBAMA.
YOU MIGHT BELIEVE THIS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE AVERAGES.
THAT’S THE SAME FOR JOBS.
YES IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOTAL
EACH MONTH IT SEEMS LIKE A
CONTINUATION, BUT LOOK BEHIND
THE AVERAGE.
[INAUDIBLE]
NOW TO THE PICTURE WITH
TRUMP.
WAGE GROWTH FOR THE POOREST
HAS BEEN HIGHER THAN FOR THE
RICHEST EVERY MONTH HE’S BEEN
IN OFFICE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN ALMOST
TEN YEARS WAGE GROWTH FOR LESS
SKILLED MATCHED THAT FOR HIGH
SKILLED WORKERS.
UNDER OBAMA THE RICH GOT
RICHER AND THE POOREST WERE
STUCK.
WITH TRUMP THE POOREST IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS ARE DOING EVEN
BETTER.
LOOK AT HOUSEHOLD INCOME, THE
MOST IMPORTANT MEASURE.
IN THREE YEARS WITH TRUMP,
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES HAVE GONE UP
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN UNDER
EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA AND ON
JOBS WERE DOING FAR BETTER
THAN YOU’D EXPECT AT THIS
STAGE OF AN EXTENSION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PREVIOUS
TWO EXPANSIONS, THE AVERAGE
MONTHLY JOB GAIN WAS 120,000.
OVER THE LAST YEAR WITH TRUMP
THE AVERAGE MONTHLY GAIN IS
201,000.
THE MONTHLY TRUMP JOB GAIN
GAIN IS OVER 65% HIGHER THAN
NORMAL BUT IT’S ALSO ABOUT THE
TYPES OF JOBS ADDED.
THE ELITIST LAUGHED AT TRUMP
WHEN HE SAID HE WOULD BRING
BACK MANUFACTURING.
>> HE JUST SAID HE’S GOING TO
NEGOTIATE A BETTER DEAL.
HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU GOING TO
NEGOTIATE THAT.
WHAT MAGIC WAND YOU HAVE.
STEVE: IN 2018 MORE
MANUFACTURING JOBS WERE ADDED
THAN THAT ANY TIME FOR 30
YEARS.
WE CAN EXPECT EVEN MORE THANKS
TO THE NEW U.S. MCA, THE MOST
PRO- WORKER TRADE DEAL IN
HISTORY.
THE POINT OF ALL THIS IS NOT
TO PRAISE ANYONE POLITICIAN
BUT TO EXPLAIN TO ALL OF THEM,
ESPECIALLY ANY REPUBLICAN
TEMPTED TO GO BACK TO
ESTABLISHMENT ECONOMICS AFTER
TRUMP EXACTLY WHAT THE POLICY
MIX IS THAT MOST HELPS THOSE
LEFT BEHIND BY VOCALIZATION
AND OPEN BORDERS.
HERE WE COME TO THE CENTRAL
POLICY INNOVATION OF THE PAST
THREE YEARS.
PRO-BUSINESS ON TAX AND
REGULATION, PRO- WORKER ON
TRADE AND IMMIGRATION AND IN
THE END THIS IS NOT JUST
ECONOMIC SUCCESS BUT SOMETHING
THAT STRENGTHENS OUR SOCIETY
THAT HELPS REPAIR OUR TORRENT
SOCIAL FABRIC.
IN THE FOURTH QUARTER OF LAST
YEAR, OVER 74% OF PEOPLE
ENTERING THE THE FORCE CAME
OFF THE SIDELINE.
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE SINCE
RECORDS BEGAN.
THAT’S THE POWER OF TRUMP’S
BLUE-COLLAR BOOM.
IT LIFTS UP THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN LEFT ON THE
SCRAPHEAP BY THE ELITIST
POLICIES OF THE PAST.
ALL OF THIS IS PUT AT RISK BY
BERNIE OR BIDEN.
JUST TAKE ONE OF THE CENTRAL
PLANKS OF LOWER BUSINESS
TAXES.
RIGHT NOW PRETTY MUCH ANY
INTERNATIONAL MEASURE YOU PICK
IT’S THE LOWEST HERE IN
AMERICA.
WHERE BIDEN WANTS TO PUT IT
WOULD LITERALLY BE THE
HIGHEST.
THAT IS A DISASTER INVESTMENT,
JOBS AND HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
BERNIE WANTS TO TAKE IT TO 35%
OF COURSE.
THEY BOTH WANT TO MASSIVELY
RAISE TAXES, INCREASED
REGULATION, CLOSE DOWN
DOMESTIC ENERGY, BUILD UP THE
BUREAUCRACY BUREAUCRACY, ON